en francia los fenómenos meteorológicos
extremos se aceleran
mientras el calor y la sequía asfixia en
algunas partes del país las lluvias
torrenciales inundaron otras y las
tormentas afectaron a algunas regiones
del sur de francia así como la capital
parís
en la región del valle de loira la
sequía récord ha reducido el caudal de
río a un hilo vamos a matri esto me
entristece me entristece porque he
crecido en este pueblo y nunca he visto
el loira si antes podíamos ir con los
niños y pescar porque el agua aún no
estaba demasiado caliente ahora cuando
vamos solo hay algas y ranas todos los
peces murieron de calor o se los
comieron las garzas este verano toda
francia se ha visto afectada por la
sequía lo que ha tenido impacto en las
reservas de aguas superficiales y
subterráneas
el cambio climático está en marcha es
innegable y debe incitar nos a
reflexionar sobre nuestras reglas para
compartir los recursos hídricos violados
debemos entender que todos estamos
afectados el agua es un bien común y
cada uno de nosotros tendrá que
replantearse su comportamiento cuando se
trate de ese recurso este es un elemento
indispensable mínimo en la región
vinícola de burdeos la sequía ha tenido
otro efecto el clima caluroso del verano
aceleró la maduración de las uvas
obligando a adelantar la cosecha de
varias
según los meteorólogos la aparición cada
vez más temprana de estos fenómenos
extremos está directamente relacionada
con el calentamiento global debido a las
actividades humanas